yesterday I found this out on Twitter
when he announced his retirement that
he's out he's tapping out after 13
amazing seasons in the National Football
League many of them down the road here
in San Diego spent three years with the
Ravens last years with the Rams
six-time Pro Bowler six-time Pro Bowler
five-time All Pro and the only defensive
player since he entered the league in
2007 with 200 more than 200 games played
in this great league he is Eric Weddle
how are you Eric Weddle man it's a
beautiful day beautiful day excited for
the next adventures let me tell you I
bet before we get to that how'd you get
to this decision why'd you do it
I mean I've always told myself and told
teammates friends and family that I was
not gonna be the guy that held on too
long held on that extra year couldn't
run anymore ends up getting benched for
the young guy or their teams I have
having six success so they want to go
with the young guy so I've always told
myself that that was never gonna be the
case for me and I am playing this past
season with LA gave me one more chance
to to live my dream and I gave it my all
and honestly like thinking about getting
ready for football doing working out
running going through the pain every
single day to get your mind and body
ready for a season makes me want to
throw up and I would much rather be
doing ten other things than doing that
and when thinking about that and
thinking about the past season and it
was difficult being away from the family
for the first time of my career and
going battling some injuries that I
never really had to battle took a toll
on me and at the end of the day man I
gave it all I got and I am very content
with what I gave to this game and what I
gave to my teammates and coaches in the
community and everyone that surrounded
me and and I can move on with a smile on
my face and
enjoy the next next chapter in my life
well I got to tell you man knowing what
you got to get ready to play in this
league and knowing how you have to be
mentally right on every snap but you got
a you got a nowhere to be and you got to
know how to get ready for it you got to
just figure the whole thing out if
you're not thinking about it 24/7 365
and you think that the the preparation
is gonna make you throw up then it is
time to go I mean there's no two ways
about it I'm serious I mean that's a
great choice that you made man no doubt
about it I'm with you I mean there's
there's so much that goes into that you
know throughout the week mentally
physically how much you do behind the
scenes to not only get yourself prepared
but to help your teammates to mentally
be so in tune that you on the fly can
help someone within seconds of the snap
I mean there's there's so much that that
I give emotionally in you know just
trying to be the best I mean you know I
don't play to be good or average or
anything other than trying to be the
best at what I do and help with my
teammates to be great so if I can't do
that and if my mind and heart aren't
100% commit to that then there's
absolutely no way I could go moving
forward of trying to play so I'm uh I'm
excited it's exactly how I wanted to do
it it didn't need a big old press
conference I didn't need to go down the
line and think a million people my I've
tried to do it the right way nobody's
perfect but I think the people that know
me know that I care for them and you
know let it let it be known just send a
little tweet out there and let it go
running let it go
run run tell that no doubt about that
Eric Weddle here on the Rich Eisen show
what are you most proud of what are you
most proud of of those two seasons you
know I was I was accountable
I was durable I gave I gave it my all I
mean there wasn't a side step or didn't
didn't do everything needed to be at my
best and I thought I I gave I gave back
as much as the game gave me I think I
gave back more to my teammates and to
the team and to the organization and you
know I think at the end of the day not
many people are gonna remember how many
pics or touchdowns I had but they're
gonna remember if I was a good teammate
if I was a good guy if I was a guy that
could be counted on if they were in need
to have one in the morning to go pick
them out say if they were in trouble
like those are the things that matter
most to me and seeing their responses
from old teammates and people that I
have confused against her coached unders
that's what I'm all talk about as the
the man in the friend I was to all my
teammates but what would you change if
you could change one thing in the 13
seasons what would that be nothing
when James saw nothing I mean I live
with no regrets rich and you know me I'm
pretty honest yeah I say I say I say
what it is and what I feel and I live
with the results and nothing I wouldn't
have no regrets and I gave it my all and
there were some great moments and not so
good moments but you move forward and
and I'm happy with everything that I did
so then what's what is your favorite
moment you look back 13 years you're
that one Wow
favorite moment yeah brother what he got
for me that that's tough I mean when in
in in indian girl AFC championship my
rookie year was pretty pretty wild you
know it was my first big time moment
playing in Indian and picking off Peyton
in the red zone was was one of the
highlights in such a young young career
start now bring
back Baltimore Division title my last
season there and spearheading the number
one defense I mean that was uh those two
moments take out the most for me okay
who was the biggest red ass you played
with Eric was a big hardest team a she
Phillips an underrated red ass right
isn't Philip I mean know him and I were
we saw I died about everything he's a
super competitive but that's what I mean
by I guess to my red ass and that but
yeah yeah he uh
I mean she's I can go back to like Chris
Tillman I mean he was he was as fiery as
they come I mean you there were there
was one time my first second year it was
in training camp and we were doing like
an inside run drill and I was thinking I
was you know I was all high and mighty
and I came through a gap kind of like
full speed and unannounced and kind of
got through there and he looked at me
like next time you do that I'm gonna I'm
gonna knock your head off and I was like
yeah whatever in about four plays later
I didn't see him and he completely
destroyed me and just knocked me onto
the ground then jumped on top of me and
kind of like snarled and growled at me
and I was like alright I'm not going to
be doing that anymore in training camp
practices I bet not so which player was
the one that created the biggest
business decision for you in the 13
seasons where you're standing back there
and you knew Sears to snap here comes
somebody to give me a business decision
which which player would that be Eric
meaning like took the play off or no no
this person's coming action you got it
you got to think about whether you're
gonna hit him or not what do you think
oh never never did that I love it I
always threw it in there whether I close
my eyes and talk about
try to make it I mean that wasn't about
me I've missed my share but well which
is why that's a shot I've made a plenty
more damn straight
which one's the toughest to tackle then
I guess would be the way to answer that
oh man I mean agent person in his prime
was was tough
jeez I mean even uh Brandon Jacobs this
is the Giants and his and his run he was
a monster and I mean I everyone is a
unique I always felt like the smaller
[Music]
stockier quick agile running backs were
always a bit tougher to tackle because
they could shake you up and run you over
if you weren't bringing enough power
mm-hmm but those two come to mind just
you know a little back in my in the
early days
most recently shoot one of the top
rushes like geez I don't even know I
mean you'd have to face Henry do you
face Derek Henry I think then I faced
him two years ago and I thought I'm he's
a monster when he gets gets it going
when he gets in the open field and gets
that weight behind I'm if you can get
him before he starts running or keep him
lateral he's uh he's not as hard to
bring down so we held him in check two
years ago I didn't but he was a monster
last night with that
well you better say he well you're a
monster in your own right Eric man and
you really are you're one of my favorite
players that I've gotten a chance to
meet and you know so I I feel
comfortable asking this question Eric
certainly since I follow you at weddings
beard and I have seen some of the
delicacies that you've tweeted out about
you going in and and breaking I guess
whatever diet you have to enjoy like sad
Nilla wafers Oreo pop tart cookie crisp
it all together so I ask you now that
you're retired
how large you plan on getting
Eric oh how large no I don't think I
will I will slim down even more
okay you know it's you know you try to
you you played a certain weight and you
lift weights to keep your body strong
right you're you're you're preparing
your body for car wrecks every game so
you have to be strong you have to live
heavy weight to keep your body right
well now I'm not doing that so I
wouldn't I wouldn't be in tuned to lose
some pounds and get more flexible and
you know lift to just keep the pain out
of the joints and whatnot not so much
lift be he-man in the weight room you
can I write for games again I don't ever
see myself getting overweight or out of
shape I'm always gonna live I mean
that's who you are so I've done my whole
life so that's not gonna change but when
my team's win and don't be they'll be
ice cream being getting eat on Sundays I
say that it's great to be a high profile
ism to be able to do that because if I I
would never be able to do that just you
know do something you know some guys
come off the NFL gridiron and they take
the filters off and then and they get
big in the community as they say but
you're not going to do that you're not
gonna do that the mental is about
keeping the retainment
mental toughness and doing what makes
you happy I mean and at this point
working out is more so so I don't have
to walk with pain no kiddin anything is
that right that's why an old service
like at this point no kidding really
that's the I mean and obviously after 13
seasons in the NFL I bio I only wish you
the best of health man as you know
Vaughn appreciate it of course yeah I
mean my mind my mind is good everything
else may hurt a little bit but I'll be
just fine man I'm happy I got a
beautiful family and excited for the
next the next Road do you want to get in
the paparazzi do you want to get in this
business this end you know what we're
gonna see what's out there I'm gonna I'm
gonna take a year at least just to hit
home
and see how bored I get what I need I
need some time to enjoy retirement
before I go to the next challenge and
try to try to demolish it and be great
at it
so I'm gonna take some time away but
I'll be around and you know I'm sure
I'll be a guest on your show so Eric any
time seriously you want to do that I
will I'll let you flex those muscles any
time you know that right back at you
Eric Congrats
you know Marshall Faulk always told me
when people said to him after retired
Congrats he's like on one I'm like cuz
you had a great career that's why I'm
people want to say that so I say that to
you Eric Congrats
Thank You Man I appreciate it minutes
it's someone not only make the league to
be in the league but to have a great
career man is it's not to be taken with
that and I appreciate anyone that wants
to say so thank you you bet take care
best of your family and let's chat down
the line Eric you got it you got of
course that's Eric Weddle six-time Pro
Bowler for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app